the Italian special intervention group
GIS is an elite airborne Special
Operations counterterrorism Tactical
Response Unit inside of the main
Carbonari
a branch of the Armed Forces responsible
for both military and civil policing
during the 70's Italian political and
civil institutions suffered a violent
assault by endemic terrorist groups
although the government had not taken
any official initiatives units were set
up in the elite units of the Armed
Forces and police for the development
and experimentation of intervention
techniques and crisis situations in the
presence of hostages in 1997 following
the successful German gsg-9 operation in
Somalia that succeeded in freeing 86
passengers and three crew members from
the terrorists hijacked flight
feasibility studies were immediately
carried out shortly after the
establishment of the special
intervention group was overseen within
the Carbonari
the public debut of the GIS took place
in tehrani on 29th December 1980 a
prison revolt led by terrorists broke
out dropped onto the roof of the prison
by helicopter masked men quickly
regained control of the prison despite
many of the gates been welded shut by
the rebels the unit has taken part in
counterterrorism operations and VIP
executive and dignitary protection
security since its creation
gids has distinguished itself throughout
Italy for being efficient and with
excellent preparation and has also
operated and operates in several
theatres of war including Afghanistan
Iraq Africa as well as in all the
countries with the Italian diplomatic
offices are at risk the special
interventions group is employed in
high-risk special actions against
terrorism the gis specializes in hostage
rescue prioritizing their physical
safety and the reconquest of vital
targets and facilities held by
terrorists and the intervention against
hijacking
in 2015 with the reactivation of team
rainbow two GIS operators were recruited
to assist in the fight against terrorism
on a global scale these operators were
maestro and alibi
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
adriano matelo codenamed maestro is a
defending operator and team rainbow
maestro grew up in Rome and is the
eldest of eight at the age of 18 he
attended the Military Academy of Modena
and later joined the Carbonari in the
first paratrooper Richmond known as GU
Scania is an explorer paratrooper while
on tour here in the silver and bronze
medals the military valor and because of
this he was commissioned to sign up with
GIS where he participated in a number of
joint operations in Iraq it was here
that he acquired his facial scar
courtesy of a roadside IEDs he was
involved in multiple actions against
homegrown threats in Italy and
eventually became an instructor helping
train tier 3 units in the Italian
military after maestro's tool was
completed he went into private
consultation his courses quickly became
at operator operator bootcamp for
teaching advanced techniques to tier 3
and tier 2 units as well as private
military companies the two Scania
eventually convinced maestro to
re-enlist to help upgrade one of the
units to adhere to Special Forces
classification and it was from here that
it was recruited into team member as a
representative of the Italian units
maestro is a natural leader it earned
the nickname maestro due to his
willingness to sacrifice first place in
order to help other soldiers during
basic training while records indicate
that some soldiers didn't appreciate the
help
who refined westeros teaching techniques
his school records note a large number
of fights was involved in but further
investigation showed there was an
attempt to keep his brothers and sisters
out of trouble by fighting for them he
initially entered the military to ease
his parents financial burden and the
raising of eight children and carries
their sense of responsibility into his
units
he cares about the men and woman he
serves with and has an affinity but
bringing out the best in others even if
it's with a bit of good-natured bluster
and perhaps more vulgarity than some of
our more reserved operators are used to
maestro and Joyce cussing for effect
though there is no doubt that he teaches
through anecdotes he presents himself as
genuine and it's an undeniable part of
his charm Meister I'll make an excellent
tactical control commander one day but
his biggest liability as his need for
change once he's conquered an objective
there's little keeping him interested
much to his own detriment his ties to
alibi are a different story however they
worked closely together during operation
spider wasp with maestro's unit taken
down organized-crime targets based on
alibis Intel but this doesn't seem like
the full story whatever other history
this year remains unknown for now my
story needs a carrot to remain invested
in team rainbow and this means for his
ending him with challenges that is
likely to fail that it's been
recommended that he step into the boxing
ring with smoke against a boxer with
more training and skill
maestro grew up in the lower-income
neighborhoods along Rome's waterfront
where he befriended local Romani
children he often talks about boxing
with the Romani a strong tradition in
their culture another option is to
arrange for Thatcher to take a personal
interest in my strength development my
strength is nothing short of genuine
respect for Thatcher enough to even
tongue-tied around the SAS fiddling the
state of that difference may Forge is
strong enough bond to keep maestro
invested in the rainbow program
maestro uses a remote control turret
called evil eye that fires high-energy
laser beams the turret is unaffected by
bullets and melee and could see through
smoke moon once fixed onto the floor
world my stroke from remote survey and
provide overwatch in a location through
the swivel mounted camera when the
camera device breaks open to fire a
laser beam the core is exposed to damage
[Music]
[Music]
illusions are fatal if you waiver your
mind if you pick wrong your mind area
DeLuca code-named alibi is defending
operator and team rainbow Ella boy was
born in Tripoli Libya and emigrated with
her family which was three years old
using his North African contacts her
father managed a small ordnance
manufacturer where he opened up exports
to the region through the family
business alibi gained extensive
knowledge of Italian firearms and
training on the shooting range at the
age of 18 l buy into the European
Championships that was organized by the
European shooting Confederation she won
gold in both the 10 meter running target
and 10 meter air pistol divisions
shortly after the event a carbonara
recruiter approach to and convinced her
to join the police force elbows
precision shooting skills and
professionalism had a rise through the
ranks quickly and she served for a time
with the elite aro s Special Operations
Group and fighting organized crime
eventually she earned a spot in the
prestigious GIS and following a
successful operation in Afghanistan
despite being separated from a unit she
was put forward for undercover work in
organized crime utilizing her extensive
knowledge of firearms alibi infiltrated
the Vinciguerra crime family as an arms
dealer she spent several years among
them before bringing them down from the
inside following on from undercover work
and a successful job she did dismantling
the crime family alibi received an
invitation to join team rainbow
alibi puts up a front that can be
difficult to read and even more of a
challenge to extract information this is
likely from a years of undercover
operations but could also be a
protective measure rooted from a
childhood
she's a deep hatred of crime families
and if not watched could compromise her
ability to make rational decisions when
it comes to organized crime according to
her records elbows family had a large
number of police reports associated with
them
her father managed to repeatedly break
fingers fall downstairs and break his
own arm twice it would seem that they
all the victims of a protection racket
with our force to pay a crime family for
protection and if they couldn't well the
police and hospital records tell the
rest alibi herself was never injured and
she shows the same mental strength that
would be expected from all operators but
psychologically the damage is deep and
this experience with organized crime at
such a young age is what put L by Dennis
path the code name alibi is quite
interesting given the circumstances that
cut short the operation against the
Vinciguerra crime family in the gis
alibi as a decorated hero with a gold
medal for civil valor for our efforts
but there are some who believe she was
the source of the leak that nearly
sabotaged the operation Ella bail was
quickly rising through the ranks within
the crime family when she eventually
gained access to a compound outside of
Genoa that was central to the family's
human trafficking operations as an
immigrant yourself she felt compelled to
act when she saw the dozens of refugees
waiting to be sold into slavery and
prostitution she tried to convince the
superiors to raid the Genoa compound and
they refused because they are still
gathering Intel following the meeting
with her bosses a reporter who cited a
confidential informant released a story
on the Genoa compound forcing the Gies
into action although never confirmed if
Ella Bache did leak the information to
force the Gies to make a move it shows
that there are certain lines that she
won't cross which is important for the
team to get through to alibi and get
past her wolves my story plays an
important part they worked extensively
together during the Vinci query
operations where she would provide Intel
and his team would act on it their
relationship seems to be closer than
that but there appears to be a level of
volatility that is worth keeping an eye
on
fortunately alibi fits well in rainbow
even after the hazing that both the SAS
and seals operators seemed keen on
inflicting alibi is a valuable addition
to team rainbow and no particular skills
will keep the team's kissing during
asymmetrical combat simulations
Prisma projects Holograms identical to
alibi in an idle position if the
Holograms are touched or shot the
attacker will be marked and pegged for
the next few seconds if brisbin's
deployed outside a false defender
outside warning is triggered for
attackers to add an element of surprise
prismo conceals the identity of any
defender who ventures outside any bullet
melee or explosive damages to Prisma
will shoot through the hologram and is
advised not to stand too close hey guys
thanks for watching
don't forget to check out the
description for other operator videos
and links to my various social media
like Twitter Instagram twitch and all
the other crap I should be attempting to
grow thanks again and I'll catch you in
the next one
Cheers
[Music]
[Music]